if global temperatures rise four degrees
Celsius above the 1990 baseline
temperature level used by the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change the IPCC and that may happen by
2040 2050 or around that time based on
present temperature sort of rise
trajectory that would have a very
devastating impact on global food
production right now the countries of
the world that are the largest food
producers such as the United States
Brazil China India Australia if the
temperatures rise by four degrees
Celsius several decades from now it
could be that the food production is
generally wiped out in many of those
geographies because of desertification a
crop failure and so forth already
there's a lack of sufficient of water
irrigation and freshwater supply for
agriculture in Australia we see water
tables falling in the western United
States and so forth meanwhile if
temperatures do rise to that degree and
in fact temperatures rise the fastest in
the northern latitudes of the world and
the in the southern latitudes in other
words at the poles where sea levels rise
fastest at the equator and so what we'll
find is that in a world that's four
degrees Celsius warmer a large amount of
the world's food production is predicted
to take place in today's Canada and
Russia now Canada and Russia are the two
largest countries in the world by
Geographic territory but they are also
perhaps ironically two of the world's
most depopulated countries their
populations are very small and very
concentrated in very very small areas
most of the Canadian population for
example lives very close to the United
States border and most of Russia's
population lives west of the Ural
Mountains very close to Eastern Europe
whereas about 6/7 of Russia's territory
this vast geography known a large chunk
of it is known as Siberia for example is
largely uninhabited but if you project
forward where food will be
grown in a world that is that much
warmer in fact these deep populated
areas of Canada and Russia may be the
world's bread baskets the problem is
there is no people and so of course we
would have to think about who are the
people who are going to live there we
might we need to have population
transfers and mass migrations for people
to work in the agricultural sector or to
develop the agro business industries of
these countries to feed the planet
because after all it will not be the
United States and Canada United States
and China and India and Australia and
Brazil that are feeding the world
it'll be Canada and Russia that are
feeding the world so the food supply
chain on a global basis is going to
shift and move and become much more
dependent on these northern geographies
and so this is the prediction that a
number of scientists have made and
that's of course going to require a
significant rethinking of the meaning of
political geography when we depend so
much on just two countries for our food
the second great mega trend of the 21st
century
besides global connectivity of
infrastructure is mass urbanization the
rate at which people are moving into
cities has never been so rapid and it's
happening all over the world
particularly in developing countries in
Africa in South Asia and East Asia on an
aggregate basis most of the world's
population already lives in cities and
many people predict that will grow to
two thirds of the world population by
just the year 2030 or 2035 and in Asia
which is a microcosm if you will for
this phenomenon worldwide the
populations are clustering around the
oceans coasts so we are much more a
global urban coastal network
civilization right in other words
mankind lives on the oceans coasts in
mega cities on all the continents that's
the correct way to understand who we are
as a species not a world divided into
two hundred sovereign nations some large
some small you know some landlocked some
non we as a species concentrate on
coastal mega cities that is what we are
doing that's what we have done
and so that has all sorts of
implications because these cities rely
very much on openness to trade they
depend on shipping they depend on
transportation they depend on logistics
and supply chains for food for
technology for finance for energy you
name it so it becomes a world in which
openness and connectivity are absolutely
paramount and in which rather than
fighting wars over territory for the
sake of having a larger territory it's
much more about ensuring connectivity
and supply chain so that all of the
things the goods and the services and
the money on which these cities depend
will flow freely and openly and that
seems to be the way the world is going
right now there are a number of
scenarios where this situation could be
reversed but the most profound of which
is what happens as sea levels rise
particularly in the tropical latitudes
or the equatorial latitudes because
that's where the most number of people
are and those people are living on the
oceans coasts so if sea levels were to
rise as extremely as some scientists
predict they might you would have
coastal inundations of water you would
have surges you may even have a
necessity of people retreating inland
from those cities and so we would have
to build secondary infrastructures we
would have to move to higher elevations
in fact and so the irony of becoming a
coastal urban civilization at a time
when sea levels rise is that this may be
the worst time for us to be doing that
because of the climate change and this
and the sea levels rise that we have
brought about